attenta belle ci ha mangiato
oggi scapperemo da ben tre band se non
avete visto l'episodio precedente è
andata e poi a vederlo in cui proviamo i
vari giochi questo nuovo gioco e affari
stage ed è super popolare adesso
proviamo l'ho subito non vedo l'ora di
vedere come voi mettetevi comodi
prendete i pop corn rilassate un mese
circa sotto è iniziato questa nuova
avventura assieme
proprio stiamo chiamando ben
arrivo
guadagni gobain
e stavo leggendo quello che c'è scritto
moore e
nonno perché queste sono le cose che non
si apprende normalmente che in realtà la
storia di bene un po strana in teoria
dovrebbe essere un'applicazione
particolari in cui tu schiacci e lui
risponde qualcosa però è diventato un
qualcosa di pauroso e balletti
assieme che cosa si aspetta senza che si
vede poco
quindi questa è la casa di ben e credo
di sì ci sono gli orsi sparsi in giro
questi qualcuno si è sfracellato non ero
io strada mentre questa volta sono in
realtà le ossa dei giocatori che hanno
giocato come opera prima e non ci credo
che mi hai superato assisto già chiuso
la poltrona rilassarmi né calda termine
lo potrò è di ben potrebbero sarà abile
molto male questa rimarrà il to in
trappola
che cosa sta succedendo qui esattamente
ai un quiz e ha creato questo gioco
[Musica]
no non sarà facile ok quindi sarà questa
è costretto il figlio la quale hanno
cominciato il creatore di questo gioco
ha cominciato a fare fare bene mochi
broom 2020 dico io vediamo 2017
ok quarto tempo c'è voluto per creare
questo b 4 giorni o un mese e io dico un
mese quando mio lavoro troppo pochi
giorni non ci credo ma è bravissimo come
ha fatto a crearlo in quattro giorni ok
ci sono ancora altre quanti oggetti ci
sono in questo gioco vediamo subito il
brodo forse sono questi
33 parma ma che abbiamo superato e qui
vediamo cos'altro si aspetta evviva
ma che cos'è questo liquido può che
costerà ppd bene come un cane mobile è
vero sono le scatolette che mangia cibo
armi e dove è finito dietro mi sono
iscritto torna indietro subito ok
questo è scritto k c'è qualcuno e non
ero io come la nostra giornata
ebbene credo che sarà difficile questo
stage mi sta inseguendo non lo posso
tornare indietro no mi sto tirando
sfracellare su quelle scatolette
tranquillo tanto curtis far accelerare
ancora di più perché venduti insegue
eccolo aiuto da chi perde ogni rumore
che c'è una freccia
da evitare puoi farcela scappare da bene
no
la scatoletta io era riuscita a scappare
e scritto trova l'uscita della ventola
da
valutare fino al bene mi sento perché
poi a fare bene devi andare tutto dritto
che una freccia
il tender velocissimo e ci sto provando
secondo me no
ho capito perché non funziona c'è
scritto che bisogna trovare un bottone
bottone quindi per aprire quel quel
passaggio va bene ma che ha preso
allora io ho tenuto il punto nave dove è
qui
ho preso a quindi adesso possiamo andare
oppure sarà sarà ancora chiuso aiuto
quindi dov'è questo bottone o come buona
è trovato prima quando botto
ha morso no vabbè ma qui si lasciano
premere il bottone e poi voglio fare
subito ok proviamo a ha morso proprio
tra il diretto troppo difficile potevano
fare un po più facile
aiuto riprovo
4 e bottone buttare dove il bottone o
verso il bottone sei riuscito a scappare
cioè si ci sto provando si è aperto no
non ci credo se ne pazzo
finissimo allora vuol dire che posso
farcela kim ha una gran premi scappato
devi scappare
parti ce l'ha fatta forse ce l'ho fatta
non mi ripeto
chi non
salta salta spiriti blu
ma capiamo il più velocemente possibile
lontano da band ormai ci sono le frecce
quadri di verde o guarda che c'è ci sono
dei palloni che stanno rimbalzando qui
ma dove sei di un pozzo completamente
definito e tutti sei persa lì non ha
eseguito le frecce
adesso vedrai i palloni che
bello sono tipo le palline da tennis che
adorano i cani che sono giganti questo
però si è colpito dopo il milano per
misti gigante via
lucio fatta
dai kiss abbiamo ancora un sacco di
stage che ci aspetta
stringe un fatto
sembra tipo un laboratorio band anche un
laboratorio del tuo caso di far bene le
palline bene cioè che cosa gli è
successo da un'applicazione che ci ha
fatto due parole
laboratorio attento poi è molto
difficile anno tanto difficile già dove
sto io ecco vitale lancio e la parata
altare qua
per un pelo del successo
ma ti posi saltato
i fatti questi giganti
6 caso taglio ovviamente nel frattempo
che aspettiamo vitale tanto già salvato
quindi vedere cosa c'è tu no
peccato così bello quaggiù corri
camminare lì io vorrei riuscire a salire
su questo
ok si sono qua ci sono delle spazio è
ovviamente tutto il vero haqqani è
giusto
di odore forse bisogna stare qua dietro
amici
no sono fatta
bisogna prendere una bella rincorsa ok
il superato il primo guardando dall'alto
viene molto meglio
[Musica]
sono passato
anch'io
allora che cosa abbiamo la henin e
allora dove siamo
red light prima l'ex e
quindi non ci dobbiamo muovere quando
luce lo stress è come un due tre stella
si
aspetta il partito del no vabbè
quindi c'è bank è girato dall'altra
parte con il verde invece quando il
rosso si gira la poltrona e ti guarda
io vivo visse felice me lo so non lo so
penso che la legge passo passo veloce
e tutti fermi tutti i miodio di il mio
compito io mi può stare subito
trovato brychan ben
nutrita tutto volevo treat arci
si trasformeranno in tv per rai uno
stato facile
per ora
qui ci sono delle sei piani in toni
pure io devi andare pianissimo
pianissimo è più chiaro di così
ma a che pro vasto attore bari e brava
ancora
andiamo allora cosa si aspetta dobbiamo
prendere questo piccolo bottone
e perché fate volando così anche devi
fare per il bottone ma io vi ho visto
volare gli stessi che ci guardino sopra
che stiamo bollani sarà cosa troveremo
ti amo ci sono delle ragnatele dei grani
[Musica]
come non detto beh ragno gigante che fa
passare ad offrire
che brutto
devescovi scrivo perché si lui attacca
devi fare saltare come se fossero dei
laser
e super difficile questo qui c'è un
ragno anche nella parete non è un vizio
rosolino gravità e qui parte la o questi
sono i giochi per cane le cordicelle
caridi
siamo finiti nella bocca di ben belle ci
ha mangiato apriremo che cosa ha
mangiato bene allora degli ossi cose
strane soprattutto delle corna queste
nuovo sono caduto dai tra poco arrivato
a parte preferite qual è la parte
preferita di evitare oro veterani
momenti vediamo se lo sapete se ci
seguite da dott
ma qualcuno si è sfracellato
fruttare qua forse sono solo nella parte
rotta ok battento questo il dna a
chi piano piano questo era facilissimo
facilissima sì adesso vedrai quello che
ci aspetta acqua dietro e che cosa
sospetta
[Musica]
che frutta al ad una piena di denti che
bono quindi bene non è un cane normale
erano che ebbero tutti questi 20 adesso
come facciamo
un sacco morto stasera anche una volta
c'è un panino intero qui metal band di
masticare prima di baciare no ma fare
come fa vitale che ho fatto a passare il
disastro celato mille volte da evitare
non farti distrarre dal panino brigandì
rasella è passato da evitare è riuscito
a superare il paino incredibile superato
la distrazione saliamo su questi
ossicini qui si sono si guarda ora
dobbiamo salire nelle cotto lady band
cuore marino sono distanti
ecco la lista dei vini è vero che ho
fatto no sono caduto 8 non si corre dopo
che grande il cuore di bella
e
questi sono
quattro cervelli
bene è una molto diligente una sorta di
alieno mostro a quattro cervesi
m1 per ogni parola di no si
libera di quattro parole tu forse siamo
nel tuo pezzo preferito o no la cacca di
rotolo me non avevamo mai visto fatto
così kakà tier ii giu
ma mi sono sociali riuscito a passare
non ci credo che sei riuscito senza
sfracellati neanche una volta non so
come ho fatto infatti
ha invitato qui pace la sua spettano
stage finale che dopo sempre quello
casco
che cosa
è il bad robot gigante
porto c'è credo che dobbiamo
sconfiggerlo ma come come facciamo
che cosa dobbiamo dare per sconfiggerlo
forse questo bottone
no ragazzi non abbiamo successo ma il
mio gioco si è bagnato guardando
sembra che sono di boom fantasma mobili
quindi continueremo dal gioco di vitale
se vogliamo sconfiggere ben allora hai
capito come a non occupare a sconfiggere
band credo di sì praticamente dobbiamo
dobbiamo cercare i bottoni prevede tante
portare aiuto aiuto aiuto io
dovevo trovare i bottoni rossi e farle
diventare certe volte man mano che ri
premiamo lui perderà la vita si
sono che non le trovo dove sono
per i figli li definì difficile
aiuto aiuto poi sale pure sugli scaffali
di no vabbè si è voluto bene ecco
bravo si tramuto punto che sta prendendo
la vita forse la sta davvero sta quasi
tutte le gambe rocky questo è un bottone
bisogna continuare a scappare ce n'era
un altro però mi ricordo solo che non mi
ricordo dove era un aiuto
dove starà dove sarà
eccolo
no non all'inizio premuto quella sì
allora forse per me quel posto bene e
bisogna continuare a scappare ok sembra
abbastanza tema io penso che possiamo un
altro movente volte el'abbiamo scoop a
dovere il bottone che non mi ricordo tv
bottone bottone dove sei finito bottone
aiuto
o no non mi ricordo più dovere il
bottone mi sono perso forse al tuo
vicino ricercato il bottone rosso ecco
non ha premuto un bravissimo
manca ancora una volta premere il
bottone e poi l'avremo sconfitto
ho fatto
[Musica]
io
ce l'abbiamo fatta
noi è bancata pure troppo ora quattro
cose di seguito i cari per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite buona visione ciao